l'espérance de vie continue de baisser
aux états unis un rapport par le même de
tendance inquiétante alors frédéric
c'est une courbe descendante la
historique
en effet geneviève regardons justement
cette fameuse courbe on a commencé à
quantifier ce en 1959 et à l'époque on
avait une espérance de vie de presque 70
ans ça n'a jamais cessé d'augmenter pour
atteindre un sommet en 2014
à un peu plus de soixante dix huit ans
mais regardez ici ces deux courbes elle
commence à aller vers le bas et c'est
historique dans le sens où ces trois
années consécutives on constate donc se
déclarent regarder on a perdu quelques
mois on est maintenant rendu à environ
soixante dix huit ans et six poussière
si j'ose m'exprimer ainsi
donc pourquoi on va essayer de montrer
en fait de comparer un peu ses
espérances de vie donc les américains
soixante dix huit ans le canada on n'a
pas de problème là dessus on est à 82
ans et plus et on ne voit pas du tout de
courbe baissière au canada même chose
également en france où on dépasse le 82
ans est l'un des champions toutes
catégories
c'est le japon avec plus de 84 ans alors
ce qui est intéressant dans ce fameux
rapport c'est que on s'est surtout
intéressée à la tranche d'âge 25 64 ans
c'est vraiment la population très active
et surtout on va dire plutôt ouvrière
parce qu'on a constaté vraiment ici que
c'est dans le fameux rust belt dans le
midwest industriel qu'on a constatée
donc cette espérance de vie qui descend
petit à petit alors la classe ouvrière
donc mais quelles sont les principales
causes de mortalité
alors justement il ya eu beaucoup de
fermetures beaucoup de stress parmi ces
gens là et résultat on a vraiment
constaté une importante augmentation des
cas de morts par overdose plus 386% de
plus quand même depuis 99 autres causes
également part de l'obésité là aussi une
once de une hausse de 114% c'est quand
même assez majeur les maladies
cardiovasculaires et l'hypertension
artérielle on est presque à 80 %
d'augmentation depuis 99 l'alcoolisme
également en hausse importante 38%
tout comme d'ailleurs les cas de suicide
avec les armes à feu aux états unis
encore une fois 38% alors tout ça c'est
quand même assez inquiétant parce qu'il
menace à long terme pour cette tranche
d'âge mortalité prématurée donc on a
également des invalidités croissante et
puis on a donc une couverture médicale
qui est très faible pour ces gens là qui
on passe donc de soutien pour s'en
sortir résultat en nette perte de
productivité alors faudra voir si ça va
se déplacer peut-être vers le nord vous
savez on est juste à côté les donc c'est
à surveiller mais c'est une tendance qui
inquiète beaucoup
merci beaucoup frédéric lors prétendre